So far we have talked about the very
basic process of case based reasoning
and we have portrayed as
if this process was linear.
But of course the case based reasoning
process may not necessarily be linear.
As an example, if the evaluation fails,
then we might want to adapt that
particular case in a different way.
As an example of the evaluation
of the candidate solution,
that adaptation had produced fails.
Then, instead of abandoning
that particular case,
you might want to try to adapt it again.
Alternatively, if we try to adapt
the same case several times, but
we just cannot adapt it,
we might want to abandon that case and
try to find a different
case from the case memory.
There is another possibility.
Suppose that we retrieve
a case from memory.
And we try to adapt it but
we are unable to adapt it to meet
the requirements of the new problem.
In that case, you might want to abandon
the case and try to do a new one.
There is yet another possibility.
Let us suppose that we retrieve
a case from memory and
it exactly matches the new problem.
In that case, no adaptation needs to be
done and we can jump down to evaluation.
In fact this is what happened when
we're discussing the KNN method.
In this way we can see that there
are many ways in which this
process need not necessarily be linear.
>> So Ashok,
earlier you said that if the evaluation
shows that the new solution is good,
then we should store it.
If the evaluation shows that
the new solution is not good,
we should try adapting again or
we should try retrieving again.
But what about evaluation showing
that new solution is not good?
Should we ever store those?
>> Indeed, sometimes studying
failed cases is also very useful.
Failed cases can help
us anticipate problems.
So imagine if you're
given a new problem, and
you retrieve from your
case memory a failed case.
That failed case can be very useful
because it can help you anticipate
the kinds of problems that will
occur in solving the new problem.
>> So that reminds me of another
example from our file input problem.
One thing I've encountered a lot when
I'm doing a file input is that if you
read too far in the file,
then the program will crash and
it'll give you an error.
It will always give you the same error,
and it's a very common problem
because different languages do
file input slightly differently.
So in my mind, I must have cases of
the different ways that it's failed
in the past, so I can anticipate those
and do it correctly in the future.
>> Failures are great opportunities for
learning.
When failures occur,
we can try to repair the failure
by going back from the evaluation
step to the adaptation step.
Or we can try to recover
from the failure
by going from the evaluation step
all the way to the retrieval step.
In addition, we can store these
failures in the case memory.
When we store them in the case memory,
then these failures can help us
anticipate failures that might
occur with new problems.
There's a flip side to this.
Just like it is useful
to store failed cases,
it is not useful to store
every successful case.
If we stored every successful case, then
very soon the case memory will become
very, very large, and the retrieval
step will become less efficient.
This is sometimes called
the utility problem.
We want to store only those successful
cases that in fact help us cover
a larger span of problems.
This means that, even when a case
succeeds, we want to store it
only if there is something interesting
or noteworthy about that case.